welcome back to another mr. B's gaming
video today we were gonna be playing
gold for $10,000 for golf Chandler do
you want a new car yeah baby
Harlow do you want a new car I want to
well you can probably can't with $10,000
I'll settle for one so here's how it
works you flip the switch and then you
get a zombie these shovels are your golf
clubs to watch em boom and remember 10
grands on the line if I win I keep my 10
grand we want to take your money
boom oh wait no the weaker the shovel
the shorter he goes so we'll use a stone
shovel
are you kidding me and I scored it took
me six hit all right boom oh that's
gotta be what do you think say it's time
it again yeah I think this is definitely
a diamond diamond you're not really fine
I can sink this oh you can sing it all
day baby
oh not would ya user would right here
let's go the far Chandler has the lowest
cordis in the lead beYOU know what a
good shot Carl grace I'm just standing
man and Chandler are tied for first
let's continue to just stop it split it
between us whoo this is ice how about we
all hit it one time and then we all hit
it a second time and we all hit it a
third time
oh do we mama oh ride to get it unstuck
I have a feeling it can go over top of
this no not at all oh that was a good
shot yep I'm a pro minecrafter come on
this way a zombie I'm gonna play it safe
oh crap slid off of it a little bit
though what you made it as far as Jimmy
didn't one all right staying right in
front me Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy I
don't believe in you I believe in you
eat it
oh you didn't shoot it over though oh
the iron shovel hits really hard that
was clean alright Chan Chan you got this
hey Taylor just come stand right here it
goes through us easy I'm doing the 360 I
think you're up to like a 5 20 the same
trick shot sink in it alright alright
good job boys good job next hole after
this hole Carl is in the lead with 148
points because the lower the score the
better obviously yo what is this map
this is desert bye I'll go first oh good
shot so happy for you man look he's like
alright let's watch where Carl does and
then mimicking exactly Oh Carl it's hot
on the only wood in here dude am I gonna
hit an invisible wall again I gotta pee
can I go pee wait I challenge you can
only pay if you tell the viewers to joke
before you go pee how about your mini
golf career Chandler say about this I
want your honest opinion Carl I think a
diamond will make you fell tight we're
going with iron I told you you call Carl
come here come here come here come here
come here freaking love you man
all right well you guys have your pants
over here and now I'm in first place
baby
oh so Taylor your representation of it
no I'll do Carl's representation what
I'm gonna take a look at the mat first
all right
Oh Chandler already hit Oh Chandler's
going off the wall oh oh oh I was
beasting out here off this Bank shop mr.
bee sting with the channel name let's go
ow don't you want a car Jimmy you've
been inside my car let me win this I'm
getting ruined go ahead take your shot
but I take my shot Oh an unfortunate
turn of events
Carl ticket out and after this hole I'm
almost in the lead with Carl flows
behind hey guys I'm back nice shot
there's no one complimenting my hit so
far Jimmy hit it from right here
oh you're probably gonna have to get
closer all right you aim up Adam oh
that's a shot Simon baby
I know I know exactly what to do parkour
he's gonna sink it oh oh I was saying
look Jimmy's happy for you yeah hmm can
we get a replay of my parkour shot
Harold now is your turn to get all the
way behind us
nice show you can hit it over that leaf
block Oh huh
guys Carl might win the 10 grand okay
guys I'm gonna be with my boy to the
moon okay you made it up one stair nice
nice nice nice nice oh oh you want to
try and risk it oh don't mess it up all
right we have two holes left and the
$10,000 will be decided oh absolutely
the second place should go first this
time Oh what makes you say that Chris
I mean Oh am I in first right I'll go
first
watch out gentlemen are you sure you
don't want someone else to go he's just
gonna go into that corner but whatever
oh that [ __ ] out Oh I'd be sad too
oh yeah keep jumping diamond down that
was a goal is what I would have said if
it was gold Carl you're a diamond oh oh
nice slither through there it's banking
in what are you doing
oh thanks Chandler hit it the wrong way
that's what you should've done did I'm
risking it for the biscuit
oh he's 15-under me right now
Oh 10.5 under I owe
Karl is this a STONER woody that's a
stone in my den all right let's just go
to hole number eight okay sure yeah we
can't read to skip my turn
he's gonna miss this watch oh how did he
do this how did he knows paddy okay here
we go
Carl's now in second about to be third
Oh he sinks it final round
chris is going he is currently in the
lead 10 grand on the line 10 G's all
right oh wow you get your zombie out of
this corner Chris please tell us what
you would spend this $10,000 on on a
better Mouse cuz that's not my fault
I think that was the mouse's fault I
don't know I'm blaming things cuz I'm
sad I have an idea I don't know if it'll
work bake it off my shoe it will what
will we do next
[Music]
in a good position to seal it off was a
good shot oh it's gonna be hard to
follow that chris is all done with 530
points which means Chandler still with
ya chili you can't even go you've
already lost okay so I have to make this
in three and so do you Carlos I'm gonna
go to the right side Carl and test it
for you Jimmy I believe in you oh okay
oh the right ways that's not that's not
bad yeah oh why didn't go far enough
nope oh oh not that I would have one
I've already have more points than Chris
all right Carl so you have three hits I
think I need to go left I really do I
don't know where Chris went completely
wrong
you sure Carl $10,000 I think if I get
it right here then I have a clean shot
Carl remember if you choke 10 grand
okay Carl before you hit another hit I
want over
yes $10,000 and my car really sucks
come on man why are you ready for me
crazy like you who analyze that Oh Carl
you actually have a chance if you sink
this shot you win oh my gosh wait I
actually might have a chance I know you
guys were saying that but I actually did
I don't know I I don't think women can
hit that far this is a $10,000 minecraft
golf shot Chris has five hundred and
thirty points Carl has 518 if Carl makes
this shot here he wins the ten grand if
he misses Chris wins by default I really
think I can Harlan I need to watch and
realize all right Carl Oh God Carl let's
see it I'm sweating so much I'm so much
gamer swag gamer sweat $10,000 okay and
[Music]
you were you are that close Carl from
ten thousand baths all right Chris
Congrats on your $10,000 Thank You Carl
what you're gonna do tonight not get in
the car